I have people say something silly all
the time you know I don't have time to
understand myself because I'm trying to
put food in my table and feed my family
or I'm trying to do my best in school
and I understand all of that here's the
thing we have been conditioned to live
in a world through a way of thinking
that has served us in the past and we
have to say it served us because you and
I are here now so it worked well enough
to get us here that way of thinking
worked in the world that the way it used
to be the world just changed and nobody
told us that there was no special on CNN
you know or the Discovery Channel hey
you know the world changed I wish there
was so we've never been given the
opportunity to even mourn the passing of
the world that no longer exists so we're
trying to solve our problems and think
about ourselves the way we always have
in a world that changed and it doesn't
fit it no longer fits so yes we've got
all these little things going on but
what I've found in my own life
personally if I can back up and shift
the Paradigm within which I'm seeing
everything all of a sudden all those
little things take on a whole new
meaning and they become a lot less of a
problem they can become much easier hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because in my first business I
struggled to believe in myself I quit on
my business partner and the thing that
saved me was watching the successful
stories of entrepreneurs they gave me
the inspiration to keep going as well as
the strategies of what to do and quite
honestly I still need their stories and
motivation today as well so today let's
live your best believe life and make
some radical changes to your life enjoy
good
the Paradigm is this we have been
conditioned
uh steeped in a story of who we are that
is based in separation competition and
conflict it began in 1859 people say to
me Greg 1859 you know I was over 100
years ago 150 years ago so what you know
it's a good question what difference
does that make it's a good question
here's the answer
the world we live in
the society the economic system the
corporations the medical model the way
that we're taught to provide for our
families the way that we are taught to
have the most intimate relationships
under the roof with the people that we
share our homes and even our bed with I
mean let's just get real we are taught
to interact with humans
based upon these ideas of competition
conflict and separation and even the
most spiritually minded people that say
I've transcended that when they are in
the heated discussion and somebody
pushes their buttons they go to that
lowest common denominator often of
competition comp they lash out with
something really hurtful to defend
themselves it's not their fault it's
deeply ingrained in their subconscious
so as not if because it's already
happening as we back off and embrace the
new paradigm of cooperation and mutual
Aid that is huge it is a hugely
different way of thinking it means we
live in a world that likes us where
nature is not out to Snuff out every
good thing that happens to us it means
we don't have to be constantly Vigilant
in defending ourselves from the world
around us that is a hugely vastly
different way of thinking we have an
opportunity now
to begin with an entire generation of
young people
who now are steeped in the glamor of War
conflict and competition
to make that shift what would it look
like to have a world where we have an
entire generation of young people that
know that nature likes them and that we
live in the world of cooperation and
mutual Aid and connection we're about to
find out we don't have to wait long to
find out so for me simply backing up out
of the minutia momentarily
to look at the big picture and to make
that shift and once we make that shift
when you go back into the minutia
everything looks different to me and
that it's worked in my in my life rule
number two is heal your inner child with
Louise Hay Just Breathe
[Music]
I want you to say to yourself your name
I love you I really really love you
I love you I really really love you it's
a new thing you probably haven't done it
before but what we're really trying to
do is to connect with the inner child
within who has been neglected for so
very long most of us when we look in a
mirror we criticize ourselves we make
fun of ourselves we say derogatory
things to ourselves it's a habit and
what we want you to do is to start
connecting with that inner child within
you that wants so much to be loved
and hasn't been for perhaps years and
years and years and years and maybe
never when it was a child
[Music]
I know this is a tough one to stay but
if it's too tough to start with you can
start with something like
Louise I'm willing to learn to like you
not quite so threatening
so I want you to this is something I
want you to do
a lot first thing in the morning I want
you to get in the habit of having your
little mirror with you whipping it out
at any time or anytime you pass a mirror
say something nice to yourself I I will
look at myself and say you look
fantastic kid and sometimes I'll say you
know you may not be as tight and taut as
you used to be but you were fabulous
you're absolutely wonderful we want to
be our own cheerleader we want the
things that we say to ourselves support
us and love us and make us feel good or
make us feel silly
you know you're a hot potato
and it's not only just saying you love
yourself but do your affirmations into
in front of a mirror do forgiveness in
front of a mirror if you have somebody
you need to forgive do it in front of a
mirror and have get yourself if you have
a big mirror sit down in front of it
because you won't run away you can't
it's too hard to get up and you can sit
there and you can cry but you'll go
through it whatever it is and it'll be
fast
the mirror as small as this may be can
really help you connect with yourself
we're looking in the mirror and saying
how can I make you happy what can I do
to make you happy today rule number
three is to reprogram your subconscious
mind with Wayne Dyer I one of the
greatest things I think that you taught
me and it's amazing you don't really
think about it but everything your
thoughts are really what Drive
everything if you've got garbage
thoughts you're going to have you're
gonna have a garbage attitude you're
gonna have you're not going to feel good
and I think a lot of people don't I
think they kind of I've heard me say
this before there's a passion deficit
sometimes right and uh I feel the same
way and I feel like a lot of people
don't give enough credit to their
thoughts I think they wake up they take
a shower and they kind of just are on
numb mode right and I think it's a
conscious effort that you have to really
be aware of what you're thinking you
have to read your your you have a you
have a conscious mind
which uh do you drive a stick shift no
can't drive Never Enough do you ice
skate I
think so so like uh well I taught driver
education years ago okay when I was
first starting up a business and uh
training people to drive a stick shift
car or to escape or even the first time
you ever get on and do an ice skating or
any any number of endless number of
tasks that you do they're all they all
start with your conscious mind you you
take your conscious mind and you say
okay you've got to let the clutch out
okay you got to give it a little bit
more gas okay you gotta and you do some
of this and you drive some of that and
ultimately you get to a place where
you're no longer driving with your
conscious mind you drive with your
subconscious mind and your subconscious
mind is that place our subconscious mind
I'll give you an example when I was 18
years old I was in the United States
Navy for four years
and uh I learned something called Morse
code
now in Morse code
um you know we were 18 years old we went
to class every single day and they just
drummed this stuff into us okay so uh
the alphabet sounds like this it's
if you check it out on here you'll find
that I just went through L A through L
now I haven't used the morse code in 53
years I've had absolutely no use for it
but my subconscious mind has been so
programmed that I can just call it out
there there's on your there's the letter
A on your that's da da and it's just
like this is something that I use as an
example of what our subconscious mind
does it also tells us a whole lot of
other things that have been programmed
into us by our parents yes by our
culture by our society by early
institutions that we have their memes
memes yeah these are all these are just
like these these uh uh these sort of
invisible programming techniques that
have been thrown at us and they're not
even techniques they're just a way of
being and they say yeah all the rules
that we have this is what's possible
this is what's impossible in reading the
autobiography of a yogi I'm looking at
some of these great spiritual Masters
who walked among us including Jesus
Christ who we know was able to change
water into wine and was able to you know
had the gift of Fish and Loaves and so
on was able to take stones and make
bread and and raise the dead and walk on
water and we say well this is crazy this
or this was just for him but he also
said even the least among you can do all
that I have done and even greater things
it's in every single one of us and each
and every one is to be able to heal
ourselves to heal others to manifest
anything that we place our attention on
to be able to walk on water to to to
raise the dead we have all and I've read
biographies of people that have been you
know it has been documented people who
have done these kinds of things uh in
their life but we have been trained with
our
that I can't do this this is impossible
and so then we have our thoughts which
come out of our subconscious mind are on
it's impossible I'll never get a parking
spot oh my God I can't heal myself of
this oh I'm going to always be poor I'll
never get this job instead of
programming ourselves we have to redo
that subconscious training in our life
that's why I tell people the last five
minutes of the day before you go to
sleep at night are the most important
five minutes of your day you are now
going to go into your subconscious mind
for the next eight hours and you're
going to marinate there in those eight
hours and you are going to now as you
enter into your subconscious mind you
can do one of two things you can review
all of the things that you didn't like
that didn't work that disappointed you
all of the stuff that's going on in the
world that you hate all of the anger
that you have it was a lot yeah people
that go through the going over and over
doesn't work for me with my luck this
will never work out yeah and look at the
way he pissed me off when he did this
and this happened over there or and then
you go into your subconscious mind
you're there for eight hours and your
subconscious mind is really just think
of it as God you know and so now you
wake up and you're your subconscious
mind the universal subconscious Minds
begins to offer you up experiences that
match up to everything that you've
placed in there and it offers you more
opportunities to not have things work
out more people to disappoint you things
that are upsetting to you more anger for
you and so on or you can re-change yours
begin to reprogram the subconscious mind
and that's what my life of work is about
teaching people that you PL use those
last five minutes to program into I am
well I am healthy I am content I am
peaceful I am unattached I am in love I
am you know I am God I am God yeah you
know and you just start to program
yourself this way so that when you wake
up your subconscious mind which can't
make a distinction between the thoughts
that you have or the actual things that
are going on in your physical life so if
your subconscious mind is being
programmed to say this will never work
out poor me look at how how crappy the
whole world is the universal
subconscious mind will begin to offer
you experiences that match up to that
you go go through your whole life also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is take
responsibility with Jordan Peterson give
advice for young people
in high school you've given a lot of
people look up to you for advice for
strength for
um strength to search for themselves to
find themselves take on some
responsibility
do something for other people
you're doing something for yourself
while you're doing that even if you
don't know it for sure because you're a
community across time
find something to serve
somebody to help someone to help us
solve a job to find a job do your best
with the customers don't be above your
job you're going to get an entry-level
job when you're a kid or what else would
you want you want to be the boss what do
you know you don't know anything
you could be the boss of your job
you know if you're working in a grocery
store or you're working in a convenience
store assuming you're not working for
terrified tyrants
you can be nice to the customers you can
develop your social skills you can learn
how to handle boss employee relationship
you can be there 15 minutes early and
leave 15 minutes late like you can learn
in an entry-level job man and I'll tell
you if you take an entry level job and
you learn and it's a reasonably decent
place you will not be in an entry-level
job for long because everyone who's
competent is desperate for competent
people and if you go and show yourself
as competent there'll be a trial period
but if you go show yourself as competent
all sorts of doors you didn't even know
were there will start opening like mad
see strive for competence
for craftsmanship yeah yep yep for
discipline you know I mean I I said in
one of the chapters my books is is
focused on putting your house in order
it's like well how do you start make
your bed
you know I I it actually took me quite a
long time in my life before I made my
bed regularly in the morning most of my
life whispered in pretty good order but
that was one thing I didn't have in
order my call clothes in my closet as
well all that's in order not all of it
I'm cleaning out some drawers right now
but
look around and see what bugs you in
your room just look it's like okay I'm
in my room do I like this room no it
bugs me okay why well the Pain's peeling
there and it's dusty there and the
carpet's dirty and that corner is kind
of ugly and the light there isn't very
good and my clothes closet's a mess so I
don't even like to open it
um okay that's a lot of problems
that sucks that's a lot of opportunity
pick something and fix it something that
bugs you yeah but not too much so it the
rule is
pick something you know would make pick
a problem
pick a solution to it that you know
wouldn't help
that you could do
that you would do so you have to
negotiate with yourself it's like I
won't clean up this room how do you know
I've been in here for 10 years and I've
never cleaned it up it's like well
obviously that's too big a dragon for
you would you clean one drawer
find out
and so imagine now you want to be happy
when you open that drawer and you think
well that's stupid it's like is it
maybe it's your sock drawer which I
cleaned up in my room the other day by
the way you're gonna you're gonna open
that every morning
so that's like 30 seconds of your life
every day
okay so that's three minutes uh
week that's 12 minutes a month that's
two hours a year so maybe your life is
made out if you've got 16 hours a day
let's figure this out 5 12 in an hour 12
in an hour
144 in 12 hours yeah let's say 200 205
minute chunks that's your life ladies
and gentlemen Jordan Peterson did just
some math how many five-minute chunks
there are in a day that's pretty
accurate yeah it's approximately right
so you got 200 five minute chunks and
they repeat a lot of them repeat
so if you get every one of those right
they're trivial right who cares what my
sock drawer looks like it's like fair
enough man but that's your life the
things you repeat every day
the mundane things think I could get all
those mundane things right that's the
game rules it's like now the mundane is
in place
now you can play because all the
mundane's in place and this is actually
true so with children
imagine you want your children to play
well play is very fragile neurologically
any competing motivation or emotion will
suppress play
so everything has to be in order
everything has to be a Walled Garden
before the children will play that's a
good way of thinking about it so you put
everything in order and you think oh my
God now I'm tyrannized by this order
it's like no you aren't not if it's
voluntary
and then the order is the precondition
for the freedom
and so then all of a sudden you get all
these things in order it's like oh look
at this I've I've got some room to play
here rule number five is get out of the
resting state with Joe dispenza what
concerns me and has them for a while is
the challenge of overcoming a hegemony
without a counter hegemony I.E the old
argument was that the only thing that
could possibly defeat free market
capitalism or late capitalism or or
corporatism whatever you want to call
this now is some kind of Centrist
state-led left-wing project but with the
fall of the Soviet Union with the with a
total suspicion and lack of uh interest
mostly significantly in America for
politics of the old left and and a sort
of a general sense that people don't
want to be told what to do by any
Central Authority now
how do we use these ideas they're about
individual Awakening to create and
coordinate a decentralized
counter-cultural movement that doesn't
sound like it's being made up on the
spot by people that just like dream
catchers and and eating vegan eating
beyond meat Burgers I mean if you if you
study the Neuroscience of culture you
know it's so so unique because
we have we share the same biology we
share the same brain and because we
share the same biology in the same brain
we we have certain Universal traits that
are that are unique to human beings we
smile on we're happy we frown and we're
sad we sleep at night for the most part
we grab a stick with an opposing thumb
so structure and function are highly
related and those are Universal traits
and then we have our individual traits
and that's kind of like how the brain is
wired right that's like our fingerprint
as opposed to our hand right so
we have an individual series of traits
and that make us unique and we have our
Universal traits but what Bridges the
universality of us the commonalities
human beings with our individuality and
that's culture and culture really is
defined for the most part by the past
what has worked over Generations or
Traditions that have sustained the
culture based on one thing
and that one thing is in environment so
a culture in Northern Mongolia is
certainly different than a culture in
central Mexico because it's a different
environment and those different Customs
that are created from that environment
allow that culture to sustain itself so
look at look at great people in history
that that change the culture whether it
was Gandhi whether it was William
Wallace whether it was Joan of Arc
whether it was Martin Luther King
whoever it was that changed the culture
what they did really well is they showed
people that there was an alternative
future that they could actually believe
or perceive in their mind now you can't
see that future if you're living by the
same emotions of the past and for most
people they live by the emotions of the
past what you have to do is you got to
get people out of their resting state
they have to become inspired they have
to become enthusiastic and Theos filled
with God they have to become motivated
in some way they have to be moved and
when they are moved emotionally then
that that that energy that emotion
causes them to see the same future as
that leader sees and you when you get
people seeing that same future and they
have that clear intention and you
combine that with a different emotion
you're changing people's state of being
now get enough people doing that
and what he what happens is you get an
emergent Consciousness an emergence in
biology is such a phenomenal thing
because when you see a group of birds or
a flock of birds flying in the same
direction or a school of fish moving
together they appear as a larger
organism when you study that principle
and biology you think that there's a
leader that everybody's following that
it's a top-down phenomenon in fact it's
not it's a bottom-up phenomenon and
everybody's leaving leading everybody's
behaving in the same way and the
appearance of a larger organism becomes
more sustainable for that species so
we have such a stigma in our minds that
if you lead with too much passion you're
going to get it in the end whether
you know Jesus Christ or Abraham Lincoln
or uh William Wallace whoever it was the
the outcome for truth is usually you
lose your life
but the real question is what if
everybody's leading and you just can't
take out everybody now so so this is a
really important time because the
emergent Consciousness that has to take
place has to be built on principles and
the principles that people can actually
wrap their mind around
they have to keep their mind on it for a
period of time where they're not
distracted by technology they're not
distracted by Tick Tock and they're not
distracted by social media and they're
not distracted by the news that that
that the the eminent condition of the
world right now and the way things are
going based on self-interests
are all based on survival and you can
control people
when you control their emotions and when
you control their emotions you control
their attention and if you can capture a
person's attention you can capture their
energy because where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
and so you could actually program people
to do anything
based on the emotion that they feel and
fear is a great emotion to cause people
to rely on some authoritative figure to
lead them away so
if there's a new Consciousness that
emerges that that is based on
not fruits and nuts and not uh you know
not on crystals not on colonics not on
any of those things but this is game
time this is where something else has to
be born in human beings that is already
innate in us uh and that is the power to
organize as a species when we begin to
heal one another when we begin to inform
one another and begin to respect one
another when we begin to shine from one
another when we begin to stand up for
one another one begin to abilities and
then damage
two people that there are other ways of
doing things and share that right
information I think an emerging
Consciousness will actually take place
and
God I think this is the time in history
more than ever uh where where it matters
the most and Rule Number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
live a fulfilling life with jaspreet
Singh how does money play a part in our
lives and this was a challenge that I
had to really uh learn the hard way
because you know I grew up being told
when he's bad when he's evil don't worry
about it just go become a doctor the
reason why so many people create these
smoke screens around money these this
taboo culture on money is because we
don't understand how money plays a part
in our lives we think that more money
is either going to make us evil or you
know we say more money is not going to
make you happy and that's correct to an
extent
because I have created this thing what I
call the quadrified theory and the way
it works is we have four aspects to our
life and if you want to live a happy and
fulfilled life you have to be fit in
these four aspects okay and the Order of
them is at the bottom physical fitness
then mental Fitness and spiritual
Fitness and then at the top you have
Financial Fitness so if we go back to
the bottom with physical fitness
if you were on your deathbed you don't
care if you have 10 million dollars or
that you want us to be healthy again
because once you're healthy you can have
a thousand and one dreams wishes and
desires like you can actually go and do
things like I know you've talked about
your health Journey on your uh podcast
you've talked about that with great
guests your diet your your exercise your
body because if you are physically not
here it doesn't matter yeah so are you
saying that's number one or number four
number one so at the bottom that's the
most important thing got it
foundationally foundationally then you
have the mental Fitness because now once
you're physically here yeah now you can
start thinking about your mind because
if you're miserable if you're anxious if
you're depressed if you're unhappy more
money is going to make you more
miserable and this is where now you have
to understand that your mental health is
its own aspect of life you have to take
care of that now this could mean talking
to therapists getting the right you know
help
getting a life coach doing therapy
whatever that might be but you need to
take care of your mental health surround
yourself with people that you love
surround yourself with happiness
surround yourself with good energy not
toxic people get that stuff out because
if you are miserable
more money will not fix that like one
thing that I always talk about because I
have seen this firsthand with friends of
mine and I'm sure many people have where
I know people who are unhappy or were
unhappy and kept talking about man I
just want to make a million dollars
because once I make a million dollars
then you know this girl is going to like
me or this is going to happen people are
gonna you know want to be my friend and
it's like my whole life will change
because I have more money but that is
one of the biggest lies you can tell
yourself and you are going to become
even more miserable if you achieve that
financial success because now you're
going to feel even more empty you're
going to see that hey I got my money but
nobody likes me nobody wants to be
around me and so this is where you have
to solve that mental aspect of your life
then is a spiritual aspect and this
isn't religious this is more of your
purpose why are you here on your Earth
and you were talking about the things
that make you feel fulfilled the things
that make you feel happy the things that
give you energy every single one of us
have these type of things yeah you just
gotta figure out what it is some of them
might help you make money which is great
some of them might not but at the end of
the day we're all here for a reason and
you want to be able to fulfill that
because if you don't and you become
financially successful you're going to
have no reason to get out of bed now
what do you do and so this is where you
want to be spiritually fulfilled have a
reason have your purpose and you know if
you don't know what this is that's okay
this is where you want to be learning so
it's understanding you know you have to
be physically fit mentally fit
spiritually fit all three of these
things have their own educations like go
to YouTube go to podcasts you have a
bunch of content on this you know just
go and learn from people that are
talking about it maybe you'll read a
book maybe you take a class whatever it
is but start learning about that once
you have these three things this is
where Financial Fitness has the biggest
impact and the most value and the most
power because now you can live a more
fulfilled life because now the money is
just like adding fuel to the fires you
can do more of the things that make you
feel more fulfilled you can be around
your friends and family and go to fun
places cool places you can have the best
diets you can have you know all the nice
things you can hire a trainer but you
have to have that you know
reason the mental aspect of wanting
these things and achieving these things
that way money can actually buy you the
things that will make you happy
and this is where you know understanding
how many places apart in our life is so
important but then also understanding
the lack of money can impact every
single one of these things because now
if you don't understand money and if you
don't have money and if you don't have
any sort of financial education and
you're constantly stressing about money
you're constantly worried about money
you don't know how to pay your bills now
you can start eating bad and you can
affect your physical health it can
affect your mental health Financial
issues are one of the leading causes of
suicide that's one of the leading causes
of divorce it's it can cause a lot of
financial constraints a lot of mental
constraints
and it can also make you feel really
unfulfilled if you feel like you don't
have enough money so it's understanding
how money plays a part in our life but
then also understanding how money or the
lack of money plays a part in our life
becoming a monk was my biggest dream
growing up from that time period that I
made the monk 18 which we spoke about
the last time I was here and so that
became like my identity from 18 to 22
and then 22 to 25 when I lived as a monk
so it's like that's been my identity for
seven years at least in my heart and my
head and so when you get to the end of a
self-awareness Journey which is actually
the beginning but you get to the end of
it because you're like oh I'm not a monk
anymore and I'm sure you've gone through
similar things like oh I'm not a CEO
anymore of this right of a business that
does this or someone else may go through
I'm not married anymore
I'm now divorced I am now not single
anymore or I'm not alone I've got kids
right it's like we all go through these
identity transitions in our life and to
me going from being among to not being a
monk was the hardest transition that I'd
been through at that time and the
question that I'm having is
I'm having Reflections on who I truly am
and what my skills are what my strengths
are what my passion is what my
compassion is and I'm saying I want to
share all of this in like a cool way
through entertainment and I love movies
and that's where the book's full of like
pop culture references and it's it's a
it's it's who I am and what I love about
myself
and then I'm going but this doesn't
align with what monk life is meant to be
in a sacred way
and that is like looking in the mirror
and going oh like I'm not comfortable
with that so when I share that with my
teacher and we're having this discussion
here's his advice and I think that's the
part that you're referring to he says to
me that
there's
students that come to University
and then they become professors and
there are students that come to the
university and then they go out and
become entrepreneurs or go out and work
and he says which do you think are
better
I'm like I mean neither really like I
can't really choose what makes someone
better
and he was just like that's the point
you you came here
some people stay at the monastery and go
on to become senior monks and teachers
and some people will go out and do what
they do outside and he goes but neither
is better and it was the simplest advice
it's one of those pieces of advice that
it's all about the person that says it
and not necessarily what you're hearing
but for me it just clarified the
Judgment I had
the attachment I had
that I could only be happy and
purposeful in this way and that's really
what we're all struggling with that
currently we all have a projector screen
up here that goes this is what life's
meant to look like for it to be happy
and then down here we have the reality
version of what life actually looks like
and we go oh no they don't match that
doesn't match that's not working that
means I'm going on the wrong direction
the funny thing is the version you have
doesn't exist at all it's just an
imagination it's it's virtual reality
and the reality that you're experiencing
could actually be getting you closer to
that goal than you even think but you
just don't want to go down that path
because it doesn't look like the one you
imagine and that's where I was at I was
having to go down a path that I didn't
imagine looked like success but then the
question is well what does success look
like then and it definitely doesn't look
like the version in your head
so to me I started to realize and I
genuinely believe this
and your affirmation is very useful to
me the three years of my life living as
a monk were like being at monk school
and the last seven years have been the
exam
and everything in this book is stuff
that I've tried and tested in the last
seven years I learned it among school
but I tested it in in reality and I'm
only sharing what in the last seven
years has perfectly worked for me to
feel like I'm exactly where I need to be
doesn't mean I don't have off days that
doesn't mean that I'm happy all the time
it doesn't mean that I don't get angry
it doesn't mean that I don't get upset
but I'm going in the direction that I
want to be going in it dawned on me that
sometimes we don't have the right frames
when we're doing something
and we don't give things the right
meanings
and let me explain what I mean to you by
that
when we start something new
I think sometimes we forget
that anything that is new to our brain
uh may be exciting and may release
dopamine the neurochemical that he knows
the reward neurochemical
and we feel good because we've taken on
this new Endeavor whether it's a new
language whether it's retraining our
brain
whether it's starting to exercise or
eating better or committing to doing
something that's of benefit to us or
even stopping something
now the very nature of how our brain
works is that patterns that have been
repeated over you know months and years
are the dominant patterns in our brain
and therefore it's easier for our brain
to activate and follow through to
completion on those patterns it's like
having a you know a highway system
that's been built it's easy for the cars
to go faster on the highway system well
the same thing is true with our brain
and the neural networks and Pathways so
the pathways are the easiest for the um
chemicals to travel across and release
the
neurochemicals you know that make us
feel good or make us feel fearful or
make us feel apprehensive or doubtful
Etc are the ones that are the easiest
for our brain to activate and follow
through on okay part bunch
so that means that a new pattern meaning
stopping something or starting something
requires a little bit more of the
brain's energy and the Brain wants to
conserve energy so what is our brain
naturally going to do and the answer is
it's going to resist why because it
wants to preserve the energy that may be
required in case there's a saber-toothed
tiger that comes around from you know
the the woods to try and kill you so
we're in this energy conservation
mindset without even knowing it our
biology is geared towards doing things
that are easy for us not things that
require energy right glucose
so why am I sharing this with you well
as you're you know on your journey of
brain training upgrading your Knowledge
and Skills taking actions probably
different actions that you were taking
to achieve the results that you want
more and better results from of
um it requires you accessing higher
cortical functions and a higher level of
awareness especially pay close attention
especially
when you feel resistance now I came out
here I still have my workout gloves on
because as I was doing uh some ab work
as I was doing you know some bench press
and flies for my chest one of the things
that dawned on me is most people do
things that they are comfortable doing
but in order to get stronger from a
cardiovascular perspective you have to
challenge yourself mix up your routines
you've got to go a little bit longer a
little bit harder
you know on the days that you want to
expand your capabilities so in the world
of uh you know doing weights for
strength training or building muscle
there are certain techniques to use in
certain strategies use including rest
right muscles build built in the rest
phase so let me explain what I'm talking
about I think you know where I'm going
with this
when I let's say do a bench press or fly
or I walk up a hill
the place where it's the hardest where
there's resistance where I want to quit
and stop and I'm breathing heavier I
just can't do another rep that's the
point of the growth
and the more you practice at that place
right the resistance the point of I want
to quit I can't do it anymore that is
how you expand your capacity resistance
happens
when you're at the edges of Your
Capacity now it could be mental edges
emotional edges physical edges Financial
edges and how does it show up it shows
up as stress
right stress so stress happens when your
current capacity let me repeat
stress happens when your current
capacity exceeds
the demand
your current capacity exceeds the demand
so how do you increase demand I'm sorry
how do you increase capacity well you
feel the edges and go one more you feel
the tension and keep doing it you feel
the desire to quit but then you do as
much as you can and as you do as much as
you can you get mentally stronger
physically stronger emotionally stronger
so when I feel like let's say quitting I
just say just a little bit more when I
don't feel like it I say I know but just
do a little bit why because I want to
override my natural and your natural
propensity to want to quit to want to
stop it's natural
but I don't want to be natural I want to
be Supernatural I don't want to be
ordinary I want to be extraordinary and
that's that little extra does that make
sense so as you're training your brain
as you have videos to watch upgrade your
Knowledge and Skills as you have events
to attend you know to to connect to to
listen to learn to expand
if you catch yourself thinking or
feeling I don't feel like it I'm too
tired not today tomorrow that's the
language okay that the brain uses the
rationalizations the rational lies that
your brain my brain everybody's brain
uses to keep you in your comfort zone
well guess what everything you want
financially in your relationship
health-wise is just outside your comfort
zone if you keep challenging and
expanding your mental emotional physical
spiritual Financial Comfort zones you
expand as a human being and you start
fulfilling more of your potential than
standing on the edge of it hoping and
praying and wishing that you can have
greater better results your personality
literally ad is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back to thought a new thought should
lead to a new Choice a new Choice should
lead to a new Behavior a new Behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
Inspire new thoughts and that's called
Evolution so how do we get stuck it's
really simple
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever the more altered
you feel inside of you the more you pay
attention to the cause outside of you so
the brain takes a snapshot it freezes an
image and embosses that pattern
neurologically in the brain that's
called the memory so we create long-term
memories from strong emotional events
okay so is that true that I just want to
understand so maybe the larger the event
in terms of its emotion to the stronger
of a hold it has over you yeah well the
more it's embossed in your biology so
some certain people have a strong
experience in their life and it catches
all of the brain's attention so now they
think neurologically within the circuits
of the past experience and they feel
chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event and you keep that refractory
period of chemicals going on with
extended periods of time so that the
event produces a chemical change and the
body needs to return back to homeostasis
or balance but if it can't then the
elongation of that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called the moon so you say Ed what's
wrong with you I'm in a mood why are you
in a mood well this thing happened to me
five days ago and I'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry I don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago I'm
having one long emotional reaction I'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves by living in
the past and so then you say to them
well well tell me the story now the
latest research on memory says that 50
percent of what we talk about in our
past isn't even the truth so we make
stuff up about the past in other words
people are reliving a life that they
didn't even have just to reaffirm that
they can't change right wow so then
what's the significance of this where
you place your attention is where you
place your energy period yes so then the
stronger the emotion that you have the
some problem or condition or person in
your life the more you're paying
attention to them so they captured your
attention so you're giving your power
hour away wow to that person right
because they're capturing your attention
so then there's an energetic connection
to every person everything everything in
your past present reality has your
energy connected to it so now this is
the significance when a person really
decides to be defined by a vision of the
future instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lower the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you and we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electro magnetic
field around the person's body that's
energy to heal that's energy to create a
new future with right and then if you
didn't want to lower the volume to the
emotion then just take your attention
off the person and every time you take
your attention off the person if you
became conscious of that you wouldn't
feel the emotion now the body though has
been addicted to that emotion because
you're using that person to reaffirm
your addiction to hatred or frustration
and if that person died you'd find
another one so then here you go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion and the body's going wait a
second you've been you've been doing
this for the last 20 years and all of a
sudden you're just going to stop hating
and the body says well I've been
conditioned this way and conditioning is
based on the past so when the body feels
the the lack of that emotion just like a
drug addict it says hey you're off
schedule here so now the body starts
influencing the mind to think about
experiences that are embossed in the
brain that are based on that emotion so
the emotion now is causing you to think
in the past if we teach a person then
how to trade that frustration or that
hatred for an elevated emotion and
they'll say yeah but you know it was my
ex's fault or I got betrayed by my
partner in business yeah yeah we know
that okay so let's take your partner in
business or take your ex let's duct tape
them put them in a cannon and shoot them
to the moon now what are you gonna do
sooner or later you got to reckon with
yourself and change right so then
teach a person then how to trade that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're going to practice
feeling gratitude for as an example yes
the person says well I can't feel
gratitude and I say absolutely you can
because you don't practice feeling it
you practice spending most of your time
feeling hatred and frustration so now
it's going to take a little time to
cause that heart of you to bloom or your
heart of yours to bloom once they're
able to feel even the smallest measure
of gratitude where they start feeling
appreciation thankfulness
gratitude it's emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened where it's happening to you so
the moment you open your heart and you
feel gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny you got to maintain
that modified State of Mind and Body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a nasty
email that I would say oh my God God you
mean you're allowing your environment
your outer environment to control how
you feel and think you're back to the
unconscious program that you're the
victim to your life you got it but when
you start producing those outcomes in
your life you're going to pay attention
to what you did inside of you and you're
going to believe more that you're the
creator of your life unless of the
victim of your life many years ago
I read we're Napoleon Hill
pointed out that the imagination is the
most marvelous
miraculous
inconceivably powerful force that the
world has ever known
and you know the average individual uses
the imagination if they use it at all
against themselves they imagine what
they don't want they imagine problems
coming
let's begin to use our imagination the
way God meant it to be used it's the
greatest creative faculty that we
possess and we can build anything we
want with it I want you to wander around
your home or possibly your office and
take a look at all of the conveniences
that you have there that you didn't have
let's say two years five years ten years
ago 25 years ago
do you know that every one of them
without exception was first created
in the mind of one individual with their
imagination
do you know you can use your imagination
to go into the future and bring it into
the present
that's what all highly successful people
do
they see where they want to go and then
they act like the person they want to
become
it was William James from Harvard's
advice he says it's the actors technique
act like the person you want to become
how do you do that well you use your
imagination of course
see it's a strange phenomena but the
greatest gift we've got
is used
very well
up till the ages of four or possibly
five
the little child
we always wonder what's going on in
their mind they're using their
imagination they're building wonderful
pictures in their mind but then they get
to school and Wham like that it comes to
an abrupt halt it's called not paying
attention
daydreaming
well
what they were really doing was
exercising a phenomenal mental faculty
you see we can see here smell taste
touch therefore our physical benefit as
long as we're living in a physical body
and corresponding with the material
world we will use our sensory factors
but you know I have a couple of little
dogs at home that can hear see spell
taste and touch
we've got higher faculties you have
perception the will
memory intuition reason and Imagination
these marvelous tools
we can take our imagination and build an
image in our mind of how we want to live
block out what's going now don't let
your present results have anything to do
with this
just what you want and it's with your
imagination that you will build it
everything that we have the camera that
I'm speaking to right now was first
created in the mind of one individual
think of how our world's changed
you see we were gifted with these higher
faculties
we're God's highest form of creation
we were created in God's image we were
given creative faculties to use
and you know they're only used by two or
three percent of the population
almost inconceivable that we people
would wander around with so much power
and potential
and squander it see the average person
literally tiptoes through life hoping
they make it safely to death
it's such a shame and it doesn't have to
be that way
I think we have giant corporations and
little league creative departments
primary reason for that is the average
individual really does not believe that
they're creative
everyone's creative and no one is more
creative than another it's just that
some have chosen to use their creative
faculties to a greater degree than
others
[Music]
imagination your imagination
what do you want how do you really want
to live
build the picture in your mind there's a
power that is Flowing to and through you
a creative unadulterated power
it can be photographed leaving your body
way back in the 30s Simeon curly in the
Russian photographer perfected a form of
Photography where you can actually
photograph a person's body and you will
see the energy glowing from them
well that energy flows into your mind
and it's the images you build in your
mind that's going to dictate the
vibration that this instrument you're
living in is in and the vibration on a
conscious level is called feeling make
certain that you exercise your
imagination daily build beautiful images
in your mind of how you want to live and
then hold those pictures there and live
that way
the imagination
the greatest nation in the world the
imagination
you've got one it's a marvelous creative
tool
it deals with the invisible side of your
personality
you see no one will ever really see you
they'll only see your body and they'll
see you the great work that you do
make certain that your work is great
work and if you keep your imagination
alive keep it active
you're going to have a phenomenal life
you know life can get better every day
and it will get better every day
through the proper use
of your imagination
what a wonderful idea do you know
something in the game of life you're
playing a cricket match against an
entity called the mind
no one on planet Earth can stop you from
accomplishing and achieving what you
want if you can
backed
against the Googlies
that the Mind bowls at you how many of
you have experienced that the mild bowls
Googlies
[Music]
good
when it comes to exercising and jogging
how many of you know that the Mind bowls
goglies matcha
soja
how many of you have trouble in studying
raise your hands as students
and you come you hear all of these
things don't get distracted by WhatsApp
don't get distracted by internet
pornography don't get distracted by
Twitter don't get distracted by Facebook
study don't get distracted by birds to
do bird watching
study all these distractions
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
why because the mind doesn't want you to
win the game of life
how many of you wanted to wake up early
in the morning resonance only wanted I
asked
wanted to wake up early in the morning
and how many of you have done something
called as
setting an alarm clock
and then after setting the alarm clock
that's an alarm
whether you want it or not it rings
and when it rings the Mind puts its
first googly
what does the Mind do by putting the
googly makes you clean bold when you do
the first snooze
you are out
you are out
if you snooze you are out
I want to say one thing just one and
probably this will change the direction
of your life you know something when you
snooze the alarm
what happens
you decide to give in to the mind's ball
and this is how your morning Begins by
giving into the mind
[Music]
is
[Music]
and it's no problem giving in sleeping
five minutes extra is no problem the
problem is you develop the attitude of
giving in
you tell yourself that what I decided
last night is not as important what is
important is what the mind says because
we listen I'll tell you something my
humble advice because it's not just
about getting up in the morning it's
about every aspect of life whether it's
your work if you're working whether it's
your study if you're studying whatever
we do
the problem is it's not about one thing
it reflects in every area of life
[Music]
don't allow that snooze be the change
you want to see in the world
one of my favorite quotes Mahatma Gandhi
if you're not happy with something
you're not happy with a situation you
fix it that's why entrepreneurs are
going to solve all the problems
now as much as the government and big
business I think it's entrepreneurs it's
us we're going to solve all the world's
problems because we see a problem and we
want to fix it we want to solve it
that's what we do that's the most
exciting part of being an entrepreneur
is that you're not waking up and driving
to some job that you hate where the work
you're doing does not matter has no
meaning and instead you get to do
something that is actually going to
touch somebody's life and that is
Meaningful to you right you get the pick
you get to decide you get to choose and
we're trying to make the world a better
place we're going to make money doing it
too but Mission first purpose first and
then making money along the way in
service of others and it's in that
combination of what you love doing with
what brings value to other people that
you have a successful business
part of that then becomes being a leader
as well and I think a lot of
entrepreneurs struggle with being the
leader because at the beginning
we are just managing ourselves and
that's hard enough right it's like have
you had a hard time managing yourself
have you had a hard time sticking to
your routines and keeping to your
motivation and staying strong and the
things that you say you're going to do
like self-management self-leadership is
hard enough now we're going to go off
and lead other people as well and where
do we learn about leadership if we don't
go to school for this we don't have
programs we don't probably have great
mentors to help us if you had jobs in
the past or maybe at a job right now you
probably don't have the greatest leaders
around you most people suck at it
but it doesn't have to be
extremely difficult
and it took me a long time to get used
to it and get better at it and I'm still
learning and improving we've got almost
40 people on the team now and
people ask me what's my definition my
definition of leadership it's I want
people to win more than I want them to
win with me
and so the key becomes
wanting the humans that are on your team
to win as humans
more than you want them to win with you
that you can have this little
disconnection obviously they have to do
the work if they're going to work with
you but sometimes the best thing for
them to do is to move on
not because they're not doing their job
but because it's the best thing for them
and so when I connect with the people on
my team it's always trying to figure out
where do they want to go what do they
want to learn what do they what do they
want to improve on and I see everybody
as running parallel paths with me so the
people around you the people even us
right now what we're doing right now
this is a parallel path you've decided
to watch this video I decided to record
this video and we're sharing this moment
in time and maybe you never watch
another Urban Carmichael video again
maybe you end up watching all my videos
and we end up being Partners on some
future business who knows you know we
haven't seen you every day in the future
but as of right now we're on this
parallel path together and
when somebody's with you walking down
that parallel path
the goal of a great leader I think
should be to try to make that person
leave better than how they came in
right have have you ever heard the
expression
um my grandfather used to tell me about
you know when you go to a hotel
or you go to a new city or you go to a
new event they always try to leave the
place better than when you came
you know and hopefully that's our goal
for life you know in this life we try to
leave
the world a little better than how it
was when we came in
and so if you take that approach to
leadership that when you're with the
people on your team
and maybe it's for a week on some really
short internship maybe it's for a year
maybe it's for five years ten years
maybe it's their entire life with you
that they have left a little bit better
than when they came in because they got
to hang around you and not taking it as
an ego play like I'm gonna make this
person's life better because I am so
amazing it's more out of care
genuine care
for the people on your team and I think
when we're first hiring
we suck at it
most entrepreneurs suck at hiring most
entrepreneurs their first employee is
not with them you know a year two years
three years later because they hired the
wrong person they have no idea how to
manage that person it's not that that
person sucks it's more that you know you
don't have the skill set we don't have
the skill sets at the beginning to know
how to even find the right person let
alone manage them and so
you know we that's the skill that we
have to develop but I think it just
starts with genuinely caring about the
people on your team that yes they have
to get the work done right there's a job
that has to get done but how we often
think about it is more from a selfish
perspective as I need to get this stuff
off my plate right you're overloaded
with work right who's over are you
overloaded with work or overloaded with
work
so I gotta hire somebody to take this
off my plate so I don't have to deal
with that ever again and it frees up my
time to go and do other stuff
right so familiar listen at the
beginning when you bring on team it
takes more time
it takes more time than it frees up
because you have to train them you have
to listen to them you have to care for
them you have to answer their questions
if you treat them like a robot or a
monkey
they're not going to stick with you
you're going to constantly be hiring and
firing and hiring and firing you're
going to be massively frustrated and
overwhelmed and a lot of a lot of
entrepreneurs get stuck in that cycle
where has this happened to you you hire
somebody you know looks great on paper
you're so excited for it to go and then
it doesn't work out a couple months
later and then you decide you know what
I'm just gonna do it all myself right I
know I can get it done I'm just gonna do
it on myself
does that happen to you
[Music]
that is not the path to building a
movement you know you can have a great
little solo business for yourself but
that's not how you change the world
that's not how you realize your
potential it's not how you have the
impact that you know you're capable of
having you know you have to have people
around you if you've got a big mission
if you don't have a big mission that's
just
it's just you cool
go for it but if you've got a big
mission then it needs to be team and
that becomes the skill set that you have
to pick up and learn
and so leadership for me is again caring
about people as humans more than caring
about them winning with you it's about
discovering what they want to learn and
grow and improve at and you being a
vehicle to help them do that
and it's surprising how often you can
find things that support them and
support you not all the time I remember
having one guy in my team who his dream
was to be a baker
like what
I don't have an interest in opening up a
bake shop right but ultimately you
should you should leave us and go do
your passion because because I can't
help you inside of this job
until I open a bake shop that can really
support you in what you want to do and
so even though he wanted to stay he was
staying more out of fear and insecurity
than actually doing something he was
deeply passionate about so I gave him
till the end of the year if it was you
know summer give him to the end of the
year to okay you're as of the end of the
year you you're out and you have to go
find a job I love you but you have to go
find something that is
in line with your dream because you
staying here is is safe and it's
actually squashing your dreams
you have to go do your thing and so you
know he had to go and move on and was
appreciative for it and giving him time
not like okay you're fired next week
and then you have other people though
and usually you can find something
inside of what they care about so the
the amount of people who I've met on my
team who then they want to learn graphic
design or they want to learn Photoshop
or they want to learn uh copywriting or
they want to learn how to come up with
good titles or they want to learn
better communication skills if they want
to learn they have their lists of like
the things that they want to learn
it's like cool as long as there's
something that we've got
that can help you with that some kind of
program some project something that can
also bring value to the company then
let's do it because when people are
working on the things that they feel
like they're growing in and they're
learning in
they're gonna
it's just a good thing to do because
it's it's from the heart you know and
when they feel connected to your heart
everybody's happier and more productive
but it's also just good business
strategy if you want to just put your
Exo business strategy hat on it's it's
great this is how Karma becomes
practical if somebody's engaged and they
feel like they're learning and they're
growing and they're improving you're
going to get the best of them versus you
have to feel bored and stuck and
learning nothing new right that's what
most people do in their jobs and
honestly the bar for leadership is so
low
it's so low most people wake up and
drive to that job that they hate so all
you have to do to be honest to be their
best boss is probably just to not be a
bad boss you don't have to be a great
boss you just have to not not be a bad
boss you need to treat somebody
like a normal human being and actually
have a little bit of care and compassion
and curiosity to see them win in life
you do that you're already probably
their best boss of all time I think
that's a pretty low standard but it's a
great starting point to then be able to
say hey no I want I want this person to
have come out of my organization whether
that's in a month or year 10 years from
now a better human because they were
with us and it's totally possible
it's just a mindset shift
that
these people are on your team
because they have something to prove as
well and they want to learn and it's not
just about you saving your time and
dumping stuff off of your plate and
giving it to somebody else so it can be
all delegated away
it's that you are a leader
and you care about people
want to see them win and you're
responsible for making sure that they
get pushed outside their comfort zone
you got a big mission inside you
huge mission
and you can't do this alone
and you may not have the skills yet
to be the leader that you want to be
maybe not yet
but you've got a big heart and honestly
that's the biggest skill that you ever
need
[Music]
because you made it this far new video I
want to celebrate you most people start
and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome so get
some incredible Joe dispenza motivation
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there I assert that if
you're not in the present moment you're
running a program and paying attention
is being present and it's a skill just
like anything else the more you practice
it the better you get at it and you know
when someone's present with you in your
life